bonjour je vais vous parler de la
communication non verbale la
communication non verbale c'est un sujet
fascinant voire même sexy et pourquoi la
communication non verbale ce sujet
fascinant ou sexy je crois que je peux
dire sans trop me tromper que pour le
grand public la communication non
verbale ce sujet fascinant et sexy parce
que les médias présentent la
communication non verbale comme étant un
genre de code qu'on peut décoder afin de
lire la pensée des gens alors je
souhaite immédiatement remettre les
pendules à l'heure la communication non
verbale
elle est super importante dans votre vie
personnelle et dans votre vie
professionnelle mais elle ne permet pas
de décoder les pensées des gens en ce
qui me concerne la communication non
verbale c'est un intérêt que j'ai depuis
une dizaine d'années il ya dix ans je
terminais un baccalauréat en droit et je
faisais un stage dans un bureau
d'avocats j'ai eu la chance d'assister à
une conférence où la communication non
verbale était présenté comme justement
un code pour décoder les pensées des
gens
à l'époque je connaissais pas la science
de la communication non verbale
donc j'étais fasciné par ce qu'on
présente et j'ai décidé de suivre une
formation qui dure est approximativement
200 heures afin de connaître ses fameux
code là alors au début j'étais fasciné
mais progressivement j'ai eu des doutes
j'ai eu des doutes sur ce qu'on enseigne
et avec le temps j'ai commencé à lire
des ouvrages de chercheurs
universitaires sur la communication non
verbale et j'ai fait un constat ce que
venait d'apprendre c'était
essentiellement de la foutaise quelques
milliers de dollars fuite hors jeu ne me
rendre compte que j'avais appris ce
qu'on appelle la pseudo science de la
communication non verbale et là je me
suis dit bon regardons ce que la science
la communication non verbale fait je
m'intéressais au sujet évidemment j'ai
commencé une maîtrise en droit sur
l'impact de la communication non verbale
dans le cadre de procès alors vous le
savez sûrement mais quand les gens vont
témoigner au tribunal ils vont raconter
leurs histoires et le juge va apprécier
cette histoire mais le juge va également
apprécié la façon
dans un témoin a même son histoire au
tribunal autrement dit cette
appréciation l'otan de la forme que du
fond peut affecter l'issue d'un procès
et dans ce travail de maîtrise là que
j'ai fait j'ai fait deux conclusions une
pour moi puis une de nature disons
science fait première conclusion j'ai
fait pour moi c'est que ce que j'avais
appris auparavant dans les formations de
décodage du non verbal était encore plus
de la foutaise que ce que je pense et
deuxième conclusion la conclusion nature
disons scientifique ce que j'ai compris
c'est que la communication non verbale
avait un impact très très important dans
le cadre de procès et que les fausses
croyances sur la communication non
verbale pouvait affecter dangereusement
l'issue d'un procès alors la
communication non verbale ce sujet qui
me passionne et vous aurez compris une
des choses qui me passionne
particulièrement c'est justement de
comprendre comment ces fausses croyances
sur la communication non verbale peuvent
affecter votre vie au quotidien et
aujourd'hui l'événement s'appelle
réinventer le futur pour moi réinventer
le futur ça commence par comprendre
aujourd'hui comment les fausses
croyances peuvent affecter votre vie au
quotidien notamment votre capacité à
évaluer la crédibilité des gens qui vous
entourent et votre capacité à détecter
les mensonges et le j'ai parlé de trois
termes que je souhaite définir avec vous
première chose communication non verbale
deuxième chose évaluation de la
crédibilité et troisième chose détection
du mensonge
alors lorsqu'on parle de communication
non verbale qu'est ce que ça veut dire
oui ça sans moi essentiellement dire la
communication effectuée par tous les
moyens autres que par les mots autrement
dit votre gestuelle vos expressions
faciales comme unique d'information
cette information-là est interprété par
les gens qui vous entourent
parfois de façon correcte et parfois de
façon un corée et la communication non
verbale ça fait l'objet d'études
scientifiques depuis une soixantaine
d'années
vous comprenez que quand j'ai suivi les
formations sur le décodage du non verbal
je ne connaissais pas ces études
scientifiques là mais c'est de suite des
études scientifiques qui sont en
communication en psychologie en
sociologie et en anthropologie
bref des plusieurs domaines d'études où
on s'intéresse à la communication non
verbale
il ya plusieurs
j'ai aussi qui sont intéressants moi je
m'intéresse à l'impact de la
communication non verbale sur
l'évaluation de la crédibilité et la
détection du mensonge mais d'autres
chercheurs s'intéressent par exemple aux
liens entre la communication non verbale
et l'habilité à négocier la
communication non verbale et l'empathie
la communication non verbale est
l'expression de la douleur
bref vous avez vraiment une très très
grande littérature sur la communication
non verbale
malheureusement pour le grand public
francophone cette littérature là pour la
majorité elle est en anglais et pire
encore il ya un manque de vulgarisation
scientifique énorme de sorte qu
énormément de fausses croyances sur la
communication non verbale qui sont
véhiculés et il ya différentes
techniques approche pour décoder le non
verbal qui ont le champ libre pour
pouvoir être commercialisés ça c'est ce
qu'il en est pour la communication non
verbale maintenant l'évaluation de la
crédibilité
qu'est ce que c'est alors avant de
parler de dévaluation on doit quand même
s'entend sur ce qui est la crédibilité
en soit la créativité c'est
essentiellement le caractère d'une
personne qui mérite d'être cru autrement
dit une personne à qui on peut accorder
notre confiance
on va dire par exemple qu'une personne
est crédible alors cette personne là on
voit de lui accorder notre confiance
on va accorder davantage de poids à ces
propos
comparé la crédibilité souvent va parler
des politiciens on va dire qu'un
policier écrit évidemment vous aurez
compris que les critères de crédibilité
varient d'une personne à l'autre
parce que pour certaines personnes un
policier crédible et pour d'autres et ne
l'est pas du tout on va également parlé
des témoins qui sont crédibles à la cour
ans est témoin que les juges vont
écouter et c'était moins crédibles up
davantage d'importance risque de leur
être accordé est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la communication non verbale
en impact important sur cette évaluation
la de la crédibilité
je vais revenir dans un instant et
dernier point que je veux regarder avec
vous avant de regarder les fausses
croyances et comment ces fausses
croyances le peuvent affecter votre vie
personnelle et professionnelle pour
s'entendre sur ce qui est la détection
du mensonge
alors qu'est ce que c'est la détection
du mensonge est essentiellement
l'habilité à repérer les propos
mensongers dans les formations qui nous
est transmise
et lorsqu'on parle de mensonge
essentiellement on parle d'une tentative
intentionnelle délibérée de tromper là
c'est du mensonge
alors que la cible du mensonge je n'ai
pas informé de cette tentative de
tromperie la la détection du mensonge
fait l'objet de très très nombreuses
études scientifiques et si une chose que
vous devez retenir s'il ya une chose que
vous devez retenir c'est qu'il n'existe
pas de comportement non verbale
similaire au nez de pinocchio ce que ça
veut dire c'est que aucun comportement
non verbale qui est présent chez tous
les menteurs et qui est absent chez tous
les individus qui disent la vérité
oui les menteurs ont différentes
tendances comportementales verbal non
verbale mais ces tendances là je vous le
dis tout de suite ce que vous entendez
dans les médias c'est à des milliers
kilomètres de ce que la science rétabli
et maintenant je vous ai parlé de
communication non verbale je vous ai
parlé d'évaluation de la créativité et
de détection du mensonge
je regardais deux fausses croyances sur
la communication non verbale qui peuvent
affecter à la fois l'évaluation de la
crédibilité
la détection du mensonge et votre vie
personnelle et professionnelle première
fausse croyance
vous avez sûrement déjà entendu que la
communication non verbale représentent
93% de la communication
c'est une fausse croyance la fausse
croyance même des fois les plus
sophistiqués on va dire que les mots
représente 7% du message
les éléments vocaux 38% et le non verbal
55% du message avec juste un petit peu
de bon sens vous pouvez immédiatement
conclure que c'est une fausse croyance
parce que si les mourres présenté juste
7% du message je pourrais faire la
présentation que je fais actuellement
uniquement faisant des gestes des
expressions faciales et des sens
évidemment comprendre irié mais un
argument de bon sens entre vous et moi
ça laisse ses limites et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je veux que vous sachiez
que cette fausse croyance la la fausse
croyance à l'effet que le non verbal ses
81 13 % de la communication vient c'est
une extrapolation abusive de deux études
scientifiques qui ont été publiés dans
les années 60 le chercheur qui s'appelle
albert mehrabian chercheurs important
dans le domaine de la communication non
verbale s'est intéressé aux émotions
contradictoires communiquer communiquer
par croix par un mot par le ton de la
voix il par une expression faciale
alors en plus des limites propres au
protocole expérimental du chercheur
albert mehrabian s'est jamais intéressé
au poids des mots des éléments vocaux et
du non verbal dans la communication
l'idée que le non verbal représentent
93% de la communication c'est une fausse
croyance une extrapolation abusive de
véritables conclusions scientifiques et
deuxième fausse croyance que je veux
partager avec vous en fait c'est
peut-être quelque chose que vous avez
déjà entendu vous avez jo lui c'est le
fait que les menteurs détourne le regard
alors selon la croyance populaire les
menteurs vont détourner le regard
le détournement du regard c'est un cas
un signe fiable de mensonges selon la
croyance
alors c'est une fausse croyance autant
les menteurs que les individus qui
disent la vérité peuvent détourner le
regard
et pourquoi les gens peuvent détourner
le regard pour plein de raisons
une personne peut être embarrassé une
personne peut avoir honte mais est-ce
que la honte et l'embarras ce sont le
propre du menteur non la vérité peut
être embarrassant et dire la vérité
la personne peut éprouver de la honte la
personne peut également détourné le
regard parce que c'est ce qu'on lui a
appris
vous savez dans certaines cultures
lorsqu'on regarde un individu de statut
supérieur
ben regarder dans les yeux c'est un
signe d'arrogance ce qui est poli dans
certaines cultures c'est de ne pas
regarder la personne avec qui on parle
dans les yeux dans cette fausse croyance
aussi une croyance extrêmement répandue
très populaire principale croyance
populaire mondiale au sujet du mensonge
et si une chose que vous devez retenir
c'est plus
les mentors aurait tendance à regarder
davantage la cible du mensonge dans les
yeux et pourquoi les menteurs regardent
yeux pour plusieurs raisons notamment
parce que si je suis en train de mentir
je vais vous observez pour pouvoir
réagir si je suis en train de mentir je
veux m'assurer d'être crédible parce que
ce qui est généralement crédibles en
amérique du nord c'est regarder la
personne dans les yeux à qui on parle
est aussi une des raisons pourquoi les
menteurs aurait tendance à regarder
davantage dans les yeux si pour faire
une contre mesure à ce qu'il croit être
un signe fiable de mensonges
si par exemple moi je crois que vous
pensez voyez si je crois que vous pensez
que la fuite du regard est un signe
fiable du mensonge
alors je vais faire le contraire de ce
que je crois que vous pensez je vais
vous regarder davantage dans les yeux
alors les fausses croyances sur la
communication non verbale il y en a
énormément je vous en mentionne deux
mais quand je vous dis que nous aimons
énormément c'est qu'on n'a vraiment
énormément et moi personnellement en
vous et moi juste juste entre vous et
moi ça m'est égal si des gens pensent
que le non verbal représentent 93% de la
communication ça m'est égal c'est des
gens croient que le détournement du
regard est un signe fiable de mensonges
les gens peuvent bien crois qu est ce qu
il veut ce qui me dérange par exemple ce
qui m'inquiète ce qui me préoccupe c'est
que des gens en position d'autorité
croire la foutaise
au sujet de la communication non verbale
qu'est ce qui se passe sur recruteurs un
employeur un policier un avocat un juge
croit que la communication non verbale
c'est 93% du message et que la fuite du
regard est un signe fiable de mensonges
je vous donne un exemple imaginer un
juge qui croient que le non verbal c'est
93% du message il est raisonnable de
penser que ce juge là pour accorder
davantage de poids à la gestuelle ou aux
expressions faciales du témoin plutôt
qu'à ce que le témoin dit est-il témoin
a eu le malheur d'être détourné le
regard et que le juge quoiqu'elle
détournement du regard est un signe
fiable de mensonges
alors la probabilité de ce témoin là
pourrait affecter négativement sont une
évaluation de la crédibilité pourrait
également affecter négativement et
l'évaluation de l'activité
peut déterminer l'issue d'un procès
j'irai même plus loin si un jeu je crois
que la communication non verbale c'est
93% du message je crois que je peux
affirmer sans trop me tromper que son
interprétation du non-verbal risque
d'être tout à fait inexact et si
l'interprétation du non verbal est
inexact la recherche de la vérité peut
être affecté la détection du mensonge
peut également être affectée je met
quelque chose au clair
j'associe aucune mauvaise foi aux gens
qui croient qu'elle non verbale
représentent 93% ce message j'associe
aucune mauvaise foi aux gens ou
professionnels aux employeurs aux
employés aux procureurs et aux policiers
et aux juges qui croient qu'elle
détourne allemand du regard est un signe
clair de mensonges
le manque de vulgarisation scientifique
sur la communication non verbale fait en
sorte que les fausses croyances sur la
communication non verbale sont
extrêmement charmante le manque de
vulgarisation scientifique faire en
sorte que ces techniques ces disciplines
de décodage du non-verbal
pseudo-scientifiques contraire au
consensus scientifique
c'est un éclat ces disciplines ces
approches qui n'ont aucune base
scientifique sont extrêmement populaires
dans les médias et finalement le grand
public et principalement confrontés à
des fausses croyances et à des
techniques pseudo scientifique
l'objectif de la présentation
d'aujourd'hui en fait de l'événement
d'aujourd'hui en ré inventer le futur
pour moi réinventer le futur c'est quoi
cette comprendre aujourd'hui comment le
non verbal peut affecter nos relations
comment des fausses croyances peuvent
affecter votre évaluation de la
crédibilité parce que rappelez vous
c'est une personne qui est en face de
vous croit la foutaise au sujet du non
verbal c'est votre crédibilité qui va
être affecté et si vous croyez
la foutaise au sujet du non verbal
lorsque vous allez évaluer la
crédibilité de la personne qui est en
face de vous lorsque vous allez essayer
de repérer la vérité ou mensonge
il y aura des effets négatifs alors ré
inventer le futur c'est comprendre
aujourd'hui
la communication non verbale peut
affecter votre vie personnelle et
professionnelle
j'espère que par les propos que j'ai
partagé avec vous je vais avoir généré
certaines réflexions au sujet de cet
enjeu
et si j'avais une dernière chose à vous
dire s'il vous plaît rappelez vous que
les nids de pinocchio n'existe pas la
communication non verbale fait l'objet
d'études depuis une soixantaine d'années
ces étudiants sont beaucoup plus
accessibles que ce que vous pensez
faites un peu de recherche vous allez
trouver la science de la communication
non verbale
c'est fascinant merci bonne journée